♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ENES KANTER FREEDOM
WAS RAISED IN TURKEY, HE MOVED
TO THE U.S. AS A TEENAGER AND
THEN BECAME AN NBA PLAYER.
THEN HE BEGAN OPENLY CRITICIZING
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
HE WORE SHOES THAT THAT "FREE TO
BACK," WHICH CHINA OCCUPIES AND
HE WORE THEM ON THE COURT.
NORMALLY THE NBA ENCOURAGES
POLITICAL MESSAGES.
THEY EVEN WROTE TO BLM ON THE
COURT, BUT CRITICIZING CHINA IS
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE TO THE
SLEAZE BALLS WHO RUN THE NBA.
THIS SHOW HAS OBTAINED EXCLUSIVE
RECORDINGS PROVING WHAT IS GOING
ON.
HERE IS RON CLEVENGER WHO IS THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE NATIONAL
BASKETBALL PLAYERS ASSOCIATION.
LISTEN.
>> I GET OFF THE PHONE WITH THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE NBA AND
HE WANTS TO NOW HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT, THEIR
CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS NOT SO MUCH
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING OFF THE
COURT, BUT WHAT IT IS YOU ARE
SAYING ON THE COURT WHEN YOU
STEP ONTO THE COURT.
>> Tucker: WHAT HE WAS SAYING
OF COURSE WAS CRITICAL OF CHINA.
MARK LADD TO BECOME A CLOSE THE
LITTLE
CLOSE FRIEND OF THE BILL
CLINTONS, NOW OWNS THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
HE SAYS THEY WILL NOT DO
BUSINESS WITH THE NBA IF THEY
CRITICIZE CHINA IN ANY WAY, SO
MARK OBEYED.
LISTEN.
>> CHINA IS TAKING A VERY
AGGRESSIVE STANCE.
YOU WANT TO [BLEEP] WITH US, YOU
ARE OUT.
I GET IT, IT'S BUSINESS.
THEIR VIEW IS YOU WANT TO BE IN
OUR COUNTRY AND DO THINGS, IF
YOU WANT TO COMPLAIN ABOUT US,
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE NBA
IS THE NBA IS GOING TO COMPLY.
>> Tucker: IT'S BUSINESS, IT'S
BUSINESS, I WILL SELL OUT OUR
COUNTRY TO OUR MAIN GLOBAL ENEMY
THAT SEEKS TO COMPLACENCY AND
CONTROL US.
IT'S JUST BUSINESS.
AND THEN THERE IS ADAM SILVER,
THE NBA COMMISSIONER.
HE CLAIMS THAT FREE TO BET SHOES
DON'T BREAK THE RULES BUT THEY
UPSET CHINA AND ONCE AGAIN, THAT
IS BAD FOR BUSINESS.
>> THEY ARE NOT BREAKING ANY
RULE IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES,
THERE IS NO RULE THAT I'M AWARE
OF THAT YOU ARE VIOLATING NOW.
TO ME, I THINK IT'S ALSO THAT
THEY ARE ALSO A BUSINESS.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST BUSINESS.
SO WHAT WOULDN'T THEY DO?
SELL DRUGS TO CHILDREN?
HUMAN TRAFFICKING?
IT'S JUST BUSINESS, NO PROBLEM!
ENES KANTER FREEDOM HAS A
PROBLEM WITH ALL OF THIS AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
ENES, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMING BACK.
THEY JUST SAY IT OUT LOUD,
WHATEVER MAKES THEM RICH,
INCLUDING SELLING OUT OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT, PRETENDING
CHINA IS NOT OCCUPYING TIBET, NO
PROBLEM.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME, MR. CARLSON.
THE NBA HAS FINALLY GOTTEN
EXPOSED AND THIS IS THE EVIDENCE
OF HOW 100% AMERICAN MADE
COMPANY IS RUN BY THE CHINESE
DICTATORSHIP.
AND WAKE UP, AMERICA.
THIS IS THE LEAK THAT YOU'VE
BEEN SUPPORTING AND WATCHING.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH AND THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
THEY ARE MAD BECAUSE FINALLY
SOMEONE FROM THE INSIDE, I
PLAYED 11 YEARS IN THIS LEAGUE,
HAVE FINALLY EXPOSED THEM AND
I'M SAYING IT AGAIN, ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
STOP BOWING DOWN TO
DICTATORSHIPS.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE ONLY
AMERICAN SPORT COME INVENTED AT
A YMCA IN SPRINGFIELD,
MASSACHUSETTS.
WHAT ABOUT ALL THE WOKE SPORTS
WRITERS WHO ARE CONSTANTLY ON
THE LOOKOUT FOR SOMEONE SAYING
THE WRONG THING?
HAVE ANY OF THEM TAKING YOUR
SIDE IN THIS?
>> I WILL JUST SAY THIS, WHEN I
STARTED TO TALK ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM FOR THE FIRST TIME, ONE
OF THE PLAYERS ACTUALLY REACHED
OUT TO ME AND SAID LISTEN, THERE
IS NO ONE WHO IS GOING TO BE
BEHIND YOU, ESPECIALLY THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY ARE RUN BY THE NBA.
SO DO NOT HAVE ANY HOPE BY THE
SPORTS MEDIA.
I DIDN'T.
THIS WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
WHEN I WENT OUT THERE AND
EXPOSED AT ALL.
SO I'M GLAD I DID IT, TRUST ME.
>> Tucker: WHERE IS
BILL SIMMONS?
HE IS A DEEPLY GOOD PERSON.
WE JUST GOT THIS STATEMENT ABOUT
THE NBA, "ADAM SILVER MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WE SUPPORT PLAYERS,
INCLUDING MR. FREEDOM EXPRESSING
THEIR VIEWS ON MATTERS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THEM."
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT
DISINGENUOUS STATEMENT?
>> WELL THE RECORDING SAID
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST SAD TO SEE
HOW THESE PEOPLE STILL CAN LIE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HOW CAN THEY BOW DOWN TO THESE
DICTATORSHIPS?
THEY WILL CARE ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE UNTIL IT AFFECTS THEIR
MONEY AND BUSINESS.
NBA PRETENDS TO CARE ABOUT
SOCIAL JUSTICE IN AMERICA, BUT
WHEN THAT AFFECTS THEIR
BUSINESS, THEY ARE SILENT.
IN ANY PLAYER THAT GOES OUT
THERE AND SAYS ANYTHING ABOUT
IT, THEY ARE GOING TO DO
ANYTHING THEY CAN TO SILENCE
YOU.
LISTEN, I AM 30 YEARS OLD AND
THEY ARE PUSHING ME TO RETIRE AT
THE AGE OF 30 AND I'M NOT
RETIRING.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT UNTIL I CAN
GET BACK TO THAT LEAGUE AGAIN
AND KEEP EXPOSING THEM, AND THAT